foreign
[Music]
as always welcome to the channel so
we're back we're continuing our Series
in examining the Jesus of adventism up
and against the Jesus of history and
scripture if you missed the previous
Parts I suggest checking those out first
the link to those is in the description
box down below today we're going to be
looking at the Adventist Church's claim
to Jesus only being a manwa on Earth he
supposedly set his divine nature aside
and that he isn't truly omnipresent the
more formal term for this is the
cannotic heresy but before diving into
that we have to take a step back and
look at two fundamental doctrines
regarding the nature of Jesus Christ I'm
going to use some big words today but
please do not be intimidated some of you
may already know these some may not so
bear with me as we unpack the first
Doctrine is called the hypostatic union
simply put it means that the single
person of Jesus has two distinct Natures
Divine and human in complete Unity
without mixture change division or
separation this is the Orthodox biblical
Christian teaching around the nature of
Jesus he is 100 man and 100 God the word
hypostasis is the Greek word for
sustenance referring to individual
existence the Divine person of the sun
is the bond between these two Natures
the Divine person the word has eternally
existed his human flesh has not that was
something he assumed and took on in the
Incarnation but it's important to note
that humanity and Divinity of Jesus do
not mix this is part of what the church
fought against from the very beginning
regarding a variety of heresies there is
no change to either of his Natures his
Humanity does not change at the moment
of the Incarnation nor does the divine
nature change in that moment either they
are neither separated nor divided the
second Doctrine is What's called the
communicato idiomato that phrase simply
means the communication of the
attributes this is the teaching that the
attributes of both of Christ's Nature's
Divine and human are ascribed to the
single person simply put Christ
possesses both Divine and human
attributes so before going further just
a small visual recap the hypostatic
union is the teaching that within the
single person of Jesus there are two
distinct Natures Divine and human in
complete Unity without mixture change
division or separation these two Natures
cannot be separated and the communicato
idiomatum or the communication of the
attributes which states that the
attributes of both the human and divine
Natures are ascribed to the single
person of Jesus Christ now you're
probably asking where in scripture is
this derived from and what exactly does
it mean to me practically speaking so
I'll give you a few examples Jesus
claimed the Divine attributes in John 17
5 when he said now father glorify me
together with yourself with the glory
which I had with you before the world
was he's worshiped in Matthew 2 and 14.
he knows all things according to John 21
17 he's called God in John 20 28 Titus 2
13 and Hebrews 1 8. he is sinless
according to First Peter 2 22 and
Hebrews 4 15. and there are many many
many more these are all attributes of
divinity that we see being ascribed to
Jesus Christ but Jesus also claimed
human attributes when he said things
such as I am thirsty in John 19 28. he
was called a man in Mark 15 39 and John
19 5. he died according to Romans 5 8
and again many many many others these
are all human attributes God does not
get thirsty God does not get tired Etc
the point is is that the single person
of Jesus is both Divine and human with
absolutely zero Division and no mixture
he is 100 man and 100 percent God the
Christian church has stood on these
foundational Cardinal doctrines from the
earliest controversies to combat the
heresies that arose regarding the person
and nature of Jesus speaking of heresies
let's now begin our examination of a
19th century heresy that compromises
what we just discussed and that's what's
known as the cannotic heresy the
cannotic heresy was introduced in the
late 1800s by a German Theologian named
Gottfried tommasius it was based on the
idea that Jesus actually laid aside some
of his divinity in order to be more like
human beings with some adherence going
so far as to say he completely emptied
himself of his divinity at the
Incarnation setting his divine nature
aside you may have heard popular
teachers like Bill Johnson of Bethel
church and fake faith healer Todd White
espoused this teaching as they are two
modern-day kenosis Heretics now the
proof text that they always use for this
is Philippians 2 6-7 with the claim
being that Jesus emptying of himself
that is mentioned is in reference to his
divinity in the Incarnation this is to
say that Jesus was only a man while on
Earth but is that what the text is
saying in his history of Christian
doctrines 20th century Dutch Theologian
Louis berkov speaking on the Kanata
heresy explained it this way a
remarkable attempt was made in the
so-called kenosis Doctrine to improve on
the theological construction of the
doctrine of the person of Christ the
term kenosis is derived from Philippians
2 7 which says that Christ emptied
himself taking the form of a servant the
Greek word here translated empty is
economic the heirest of Kino a
misinterpretation of this passage became
the scriptural basis for the kenosis
Doctrine along with second Corinthians 8
9. these passages were interpreted as
teaching that Christ at the Incarnation
emptied or divested himself of his
divinity this Theory once very popular
in one form or another and still
defended by some has now lost a great
deal of its charm it is subversive to
the doctrine of the Trinity contrary to
that of the immutability of God and at
variance with those passages of
scripture which ascribe Divine
attributes to the historical Jesus in
the most absolute and most consistent
form it teaches what latouche calls
Incarnation by Divine suicide
so excellently put this heresy causes
all sorts of theological blunders
regarding the godhead as well as the
person of Jesus Christ so what is
Philippians 2 actually teaching if it
isn't this after all the text does say
that Jesus emptied himself upon
incarnating right let's read Philippians
2 5-8 where it says
have this mind among yourselves which is
yours in Christ Jesus who though he was
in the form of God did not count
equality with God a thing to be grasped
but emptied himself by taking the form
of a servant being born in the likeness
of men and being found in human form he
humbled himself by becoming obedient to
the point of death even death on a cross
Paul is not saying that Jesus emptied
himself of his divinity he is giving an
exhortation to be like Christ who
humbled himself he is describing the
leaving of his rightful estate to Abode
within his own creation and he did so by
taking the form of a human in a sinful
world through Incarnation the context
has nothing to do with Jesus giving up
his divinity temporarily Paul is using
Christ's Act of incarnating as an
exhortation for us to be like him are we
supposed to give up our divine
attributes of course not we aren't
Divine Paul is simply using Christ's
willful humiliation as an example for us
to do the same be humble servants of God
commenting on this set of verses in his
commentary on Philippians Saint
Augustine summarizes what Paul is saying
perfectly he says
he is said to have emptied himself in no
other way than by taking the form of a
servant not by losing the form of God
for that nature by which he is equal to
the father in the form of God remained
immutable while he took our mutable
nature through which he was born of the
Virgin he did not take on his Humanity
in the simple way that a person puts on
clothes as something exterior to him
rather he took on human form in a manner
inexpressibly more excellent and more
intimate than that the Apostle has made
it sufficiently clear what he meant he
was made to appear in human likeness he
was not exhaustively reduced to being a
man he rather assumed the true human
estate when he put on the man
so Augustine properly recognized that
the grammar and context of the passage
is speaking to Christ's function as the
divine Savior not to him shedding
himself of his divinity and setting it
aside rather Christ added unto himself a
human nature while retaining his true
Divinity 100 man 100 God the same
understanding is found among the
Primitive Eastern Church writing in the
5th Century Cyril of Alexandria
commenting specifically on Philippians 2
7 wrote this
what sort of emptying is this to assume
the flesh even in the form of a slave a
likeness to ourselves while not being
like us in his own nature but superior
to the whole creation thus he humbled
himself descending by his economy into
mortal bounds Cyril also recognized that
Paul's point is that Jesus Took the form
of a slave in the likeness of man but in
doing so he was still Superior to all
the creation he is the god man he did
not discard himself of his divine nature
for a period And reassume it later or in
the Adventist Jesus's case never fully
gain it back as we will see Cyril and
Augustine along with theologians and
commentators of the Christian Church
down through the centuries have all
properly and consistently recognized the
point that Paul was making this is not
answering adventism's private
interpretation I happily and humbly
stand on the shoulders of giants the
canosis interpretation is not only a
heresy but a fringe minority so with
that in mind how does the Adventist
Jesus align with this remember there is
no separating the two Natures within the
single person first I want to look at a
paper from 1998 in the digital art
Archive of the Adventist theological
Society in international theological
resource for The Seventh-Day Adventist
Church where we get a glimpse into how
adventism has equipped Adventists to
think about this we read
in the person of Jesus Christ he
sacrificed his omnipresence to become
one of his creation he sacrificed his
omniscience to find his mission by faith
as we must he sacrificed his omnipotence
to let his Rebel creation pound nails
through his hands so did you get that
this Adventist claims that Jesus shed
his omnipotence omnipresence and
omniscience upon incarnating meaning he
was not God while he was on Earth
despite the fact that Hebrews 1 3 tells
us that Jesus Christ upholds the
universe by the word of his power and
Colossians 1 17 which tells us that
Christ who holds all things together and
Colossians 2 9 which says that he is the
fullness of the godhead bodily the
Adventist Jesus was not fully and truly
God while he was on Earth he was limited
in fact the Adventists believed 28
fundamental beliefs book speaking on
Christ's omnipresence while incarnate
says this
although his divinity has the natural
ability of omnipresence the Incarnate
Christ has voluntarily limited himself
in this respect he has chosen to be
omnipresent through the ministry of the
Holy Spirit John 14 16-18 so this means
the Adventist Jesus will forever be
limited in his omnipresence because he
will forever remain incarnate but
furthermore Jesus saying that he would
send the Holy Spirit to the disciples in
John 14 in no way shape or form means
that he himself is not truly fully
omnipresent his human nature is not
omnipresent but his divine nature is
however it is the one person of Christ
who shares in both Natures that's the
communication of the attributes and it's
the one person who is omnipresent Jesus
possesses omnipresence entirely it is
not something that can be flipped on and
off like a switch not even one of those
kind that allows you to dim the light
without fully turning it off furthermore
on the Adventist Church's website within
the fundamental belief regarding Christ
the Inc our nation and his resurrection
we read the following
this concept that Jesus is 100 God and
100 human can be mind-boggling but this
was necessary in God's plan to Deliver
Us from the group of sin while the great
controversy rages on meaning both good
and evil surround us daily warring
against one another so minus the great
controversy caveat that sounds great but
then notice what they say Philippians 2
6-8 says that even though Jesus Is God
he set his divine nature aside and took
on human nature
ah in typical par for the course fashion
the Adventist Church pays lip service to
Christian Orthodoxy in this case the
hypothetic union only to immediately
contradict themselves a mere two
paragraphs later they claim to affirm
the hypostatic union even Bolding the
text to make it stand out this is
because they know this is what
Christians believe and they want to try
and make sure they appear in line with
that but then they give the standard
cannotic interpretation of Philippians 2
which completely contradicts the
hypothetic union Jesus did not set his
divine nature aside but this is
necessary in the SDA system of theology
because Jesus had to be just a man like
we are as the great example to
demonstrate and show that the law of God
can be kept perfectly in the great
controversy as we saw was even mentioned
on their website everything in Adventist
theology is filtered through the great
controversy theme yet at the same time
their theologians and Scholars
understand how fundamental the
hypothetic union is to Christianity
which puts them in a cognitive bind on
the one hand they have to uphold the
great controversy worldview which would
mean upholding Ellen White as well on
the other they want to try and appear
like Orthodox Christians and this is the
Catch-22 that will forever plague the
Adventist Church so yet again we see
that the Adventist Jesus is not the
Jesus of history or scripture if Jesus
set aside any of his Divine attributes
he ceased being God because it's the
Divine attributes of God that make God
what he is by nature Jesus wouldn't have
been the fullness of the godhead bodily
if this were so and this is a major
problem
hey y'all thanks for watching if you
like content like this want to partner
with us or access more resources visit
answeringadmonism.com and learn more as
always until next time God bless
[Music]